hey guys welcome to the rumen report i'm
dave rubin
we are doing a one on one this week we
have a guy who needs no introduction
and truly a living legend about that
intro
dead legit better than a dead leg in
larry king welcome to the room in
reporting your name
great to be with you always have love
having you on my show and scraped to
return the compliment I appreciate that
actually the first time I was on your
show I am sweating
bit when we did that Republican National
Convention and you told
that you told me I was sweating more
than albert brooks in broadcast news
which is
truly one of the greatest moment in my
career broadcast news is one bit
all-time great
movies I think great great movie about
the media
well for everything we do right and for
me especially because
I saw that movie two weeks after
quintuple bypass surgery
well and i sat next to Mike Wallace
arisen Diane so the whole
the whole in crowded New York in my
surgery was in New York
so we all attended that film in
everybody loved
yeah I will you know let's start with a
little bit about the media so you have
been around the media for basically your
whole life in at least 57 years
57 years but who's counting what what do
you think you're the biggest changes
in the way the media landscape as you
know you're you're doing an online show
now
we're doing some major changes one
technical
in that when I started there was a radio
and television
landlines and telephone lines and then
came satellites and now we have
internet not long ago technological and
has been incredible
and that has led to five hundred
channels in anything goes in
you know when jackie gleason went off
the air
he have $13.3 million viewers there was
no show the
that approach is $20 million viewers so
the
the pie is cut up in many many slices
and we all have a little piece a slice
piece a pyro so when I left
CNN I thought I could retire then along
came Carlos lemon
the internet now I'm on the internet
every day who knows
who knows what's next the delivery
system now
the basic hasn't changed this one-on-one
has not changed we still need the human
being
it has bad hasn't changed the method of
delivery
has changed are we losing something with
the one-on-one I mean really what your
trademark is this what we're doing right
now
we don't get that in a way that we use
noon sadly enough because it's a
is spirit heated up speed about Gordon
actually
no course there's up grab some job on
this day
bang it out but men go was over it was
next and love it leads to
I'm some love it is absurd the I miss
in-depth interviews you don't see much
in that
anymore on on cable television on you
know it's going away everywhere
said do you think it's just a function
of technology or is there actually
something else go is there something
about
humans and the way we're evolving under
no babies but Youmans or or about
management or about the people running
networks now or will call
suits mmm they didn't go up to broadcast
their captains
they're up to that pushes you know
they're big big world what this works
that does or keep business there's a war
going on
classic example was it mile network CNN
which is
I'm I loved every day on my twenty five
and a half years there
I did a lot for them they did a lot for
me it was a great career ted turner was
the best person I've worked for
work I didn't speak to to this bigoted
recently but if he saw was going on now
for example the airplane yet with let's
go another example
then covered that 24 hours a day they
missed
in you had the russians going into
Ukraine
the other day in one day i watch the
show on CRP official but they never
mention
other news was airplay yeah and and the
airplane was all conjecture
we think it landed here we might have
gone he would be since day to day man
that
advanced nothing in that story but
conjecture it was
breaking the supposition breaking the
speculation was never breaking news
so if you were there now I don't know
what the hell with that but he
or item II love insisted the two other
things %uh they were said we got a
tremendous audience
then well the network I would've gone or
I with there's nothing I could do was to
break it
I would have tried heard for example the
other day
while CNN and some other cable news
networks I'm sure we're doing
airplane coast to coast wire to wire
10 people in Washington
yup were killed in a mudslide they would
three Americans on a plane
10 Americans died in a mudslide in
washington no coverage
the g8 conference in Russia was
cancelled
reschedule for Belgium with Russia left
out
no mention an enormous
enormous occurrence in Houston up an oil
slick
that described hundreds and hundreds of
miles
water not covered the president of the
united states
is in the Netherlands he's talking to
china
about trying to get China to at least a
neutral in the russian situation
no coverage yet know that is abysmal
so who do we blame for this because I
I'm with you everybody Matt Mills this
but it is a matter above readings
bridges ladies purses logic
yeah so why did so we hear about it but
the and the reason that that doesn't
work is
or you get super ratings and you think
advertisers don't know
that these ratings are based on the
hyped up there okay
to what happens after the incident is
over whenever dance and you gotta decide
when this and when is a public lose
interest
when you go back to your the program
missing down again the advertising gonna
buy it for the next six months
based on that too with jump because they
don't know what it was like
buying I'm gonna buy CBS I wanna buy
NBC per year because boy the Super Bowl
did great
I rests on sobel the great I've been to
buy NBC next tuesday
a normal person has nothing to do with
the other but thats
let's think and it's it's said to be so
what we do to change it so
you for example you're on ora TV now
which is an online news network we here
at The Young Turks were an online news
network type
Burnley believe that this is the future
initial is she can we reach three
million people
forward do they get you know it'll grow
yeah in Middleboro talk the
it all balances out up about predicting
the future in this business is
in possible yeah there's
when I started in radio in Miami in 1957
University Miami owned an FM station
and at them was considered background
music wasn't
firm rate they gave that station
to the University of Miami the universe
Miami later solar station which became
the number one problem how station
in Miami if you to set in 1957
AF firms gonna really takeoff frequency
much
tama right you kid so I
I so I've learned not to predict right
any did okay for about the last fifty
years ago
they've they've been around so if we
can't predict it what do you make of the
general partisan nature abuse because to
me that's been the thing in the last ten
years
and i were really use it the most that's
one thing about CNN that has
CNN has stayed in the middle which is a
tough place to be
Yap do not hurt them in a way because
everyone is so partisan any thought not
in our view CNN's credit
I'm happy that they have stayed not they
strayed a little sometimes you'll see
opinions
hmm up I don't a shower
a growing Bishop I always thought that
my opinion as an interview with didn't
count
but I was there to learn from what the
guest spot
I let my ego at the door the name my
show was in them
the name the shows larry king live so
I'll be back
same to you i know i so was who what
where when why and the guest counted
on a lot only shows the guest is a prop
for the host
the hosts use the word I'll I is
irrelevant I don't care what the
hostnames
acute the if I never if I got a lawyer
either normal or than a lawyer
I'm never voted in the senate I never
carried a gun
as weapon in war I never performed an
operation
how could I know more about medicine the
doctor yeah
I'm you're also I might have my personal
opinions on things but I certainly
value the guest and what that guess
that's the sabin at agree with that
so let me come through me as a conduit
you know i think thats lost
so when you had moments that you really
disagreed with someone on here it is
part was the Indian moral issue job to
me that the hardest part was admiration
racial issue I when I had the interview
george wallace
the governor Alabama nearly he changed
significantly
are that was tough and sometimes I did
get into arguments but I found
that in those moral areas when I got
into an argument
what happened was it may have seemed
exciting you can learn anything
it was just two people yelling at each
other that's effective
but you know ratings are up
jackie gleason was a meant to remind and
a great man
Jackie told me so you know
power leo's is a POW I could put
intercourse on television on CBS
Tuesday night three hours I'm gonna wipe
you out there
you might as well not even go anywhere
else I own America
rate that's not talent rate and that was
before
lucy could even put the bed together so
alright yeah burning
of course yeah if you could titillate
this minded people an appeal to their
pre and interest I'm going on the night
yeah takes note I'll so let's talk a
little bit about politicians then
speaking
a ratings and the ability to get someone
to tell the truth they
often I now see these interview shows
and politicians
have a way up no matter what you as the
interviewer asked
they answer completely different
question and and they shamelessly do it
how to use or directly honest
get shoved to the side would occur barry
goldwater and george mcgovern were two
classic examples
i've interviewed the both many times and
both Pestano
barry goldwater on george mcgovern had
no cut-off between the brain and the mob
wrestle question-and-answer right wiped
out in national elections because the
public
and the we we in the media say we want
their a donde sea and we'll ambassador
if you directly on so what the
politician tries to do
is home to my season p the best tip
anyway if you're watching
an interview show the politician and
pick guess this as the question
and the politicians those I'm glad you
asked that
is the truth he sold me not to
administer and he has said i'm glad US
that
so he can think how to answer it
that will appeal to the largest common
denominated
so I'm guessing you probably heard that
about four billion time within 25 years
on CNN now till you do the best you can
what I try to do is get at the core
things I try to ask good questions
come around a lot always but I on the
other hand
have great respect for politicians for
this reason
they do something that we don't do one
they stand up and be counted and
they have what we now have never had in
our lives
they have a Tuesday in November
where the school goes up and we don't do
that we have ratings but that sporadic
correct score goes up so I've always
respected politicians and athletes
athletes have something we don't have
one their livelihood ends when most of
our
really good livelihood begins the
cheering stops
when their 40 our children's in life
starts at forty
pretty much number two they have a final
score
you know painted you lost you know
we don't have a final score yeah I
didn't lose 4-3 today
somebody was for some weekly best
Wallace and the one team scored a 100
2011 team scored 97
you can call you want the people on 97
lost the loss to is that it right there
is that the problem with the media that
we don't score things the other
I respect at least because they face
that yeah iris but politicians because
they get a Tuesday November
that we don't have so I begin with
respect for a man who ran for
then I can if he gets drawn to store off
the beaten track then
you know you tried it I you try to learn
as much as you can also try to do in
interviewing was learn as much as I can
when I yelled at people
I never learned anything yup I was on
your show last week
and Dennis Prager was on who is a
conservative radio host who I don't
agree with especially on
the social stuff and you've been a big
supporter a bill GBT the gay community
and I could see you were getting into it
a little bit with him but with it was
based in respect and I'm sure this
program for years and I like him
now I don't agree with him I think that
the gay issue he is way off track but he
comes
from a religious bent NES the question
that cool because you think that one one
thing I like I like about questions
the course when Dennis Prager said if
you had to people
you know the judge someone's gonna get
this child a gay couple
or at a central couple and their equally
values
who would you give the job to and I
think the crowd as you might give it a
gay couple might
what would have been a but I can see
where he's coming from
where you can make a case for that
and I like great moral arguments like
that when the Sun was presented to me
because it causes what we want to do is
think we want to progress we want to
thank
a written article the other day should
we be mad
at woody allen should we not see a Woody
Allen movie
because of what he did with supposedly
his young son
should we not so big question was posed
this way
and I love this suppose I showed you a
great painting
and you loved it one-upping it captured
drama
Beneteau to Hitler painted was your
opinion that the painting
change he probably would why
I guess that wouldn't be in the most
purest our descent over it but it
knowing where it came from can you
separate the art
from the our daughters but it does a
great moral questions we asked them all
the time
that's the kind of thing II that's a
kinda give-and-take
where you could have a guest I who may
not want to buy the painting
but the guest could defend get by a
painting Mon its value at its core
yeah right and that's does a great
arguments don't see any more
so speaking up that do you see the the
gay the movement as
sure the civil rights idea I know that
part time however I went through a lot
of things
no would have been a business 57 is I
was in miami
when anita bryant yeah started the
let's be civil with that was an anti-gay
movement now we have a
about to give gays the right open
housing in
the biggest attacked on that vote
was the blacks they were in ninety-eight
percent against it
against a bill the world given gays
complete rights in Miami
and the reason was they said don't put
us in the gay rights category
we we have a color right-wing we're not
gays thats completely change
gay is a civil rights issue and what the
the people opposed to have two phases
it's a losing war
Bryant you done Cody so in other
politicians then because these people if
they want one thing it's to remain in
power rate Matt the part that I don't
see it change
I saw george wallace yeah go from
barring the door at the University of
Alabama not letting a student and
to his chief of staff being black
yeah I sorta I I lived in this
when I arrived in Miami to break into
broadcasting
I don't have to train and the first
thing I saw was a water problem is a
color only and I drank a lot from
was good war then another bus to go over
to miami Beach since they were my uncle
nice and the bike tour bus and the bus
driver pulled over and said you have to
move the front
was the back to the bus for negroes and
the from the buses forwards
aka believe that I was for both there so
I said my father's black
I known was in the middle
weary of segregation be the others
stupidity of it
but I'm in Miami
a progressive city in 1957
blacks and whites couldn't compete
against each other on the football field
yeah cannot grow now missus
all these teams out the entire
mississippi best four teams black
yeah Alabama best fucking what perot
yeah Mills sources yeah he was so now
we've seen medically we have a black
president
yes we'll have a gay president yes we'll
ever female person
life exchange and the politician will
have to change along with it
or blues right will you give me a
perfect segue into a little let's do a
little bit
love political footballing 226 teens
coming we talked a little bit about it
on your show
hilary is i mean is it a foregone
conclusion as much I I know he wants to
choose a nominee I don't think any I
don't think by more against her
I think up with the problems that he'll
be secretary state I think that's
logical to think that he would be be
great sixty
to what do you make of the idea that we
have these families then you know that
it would be the bush on the closures
totally oppose
against it yeah probably has one job to
run the a
you know she says I love barbara Bush
one of my favorite people help
stop with this forever I stop with the
bushes in the current stop
yeah we have enough but isn't that how
most american feels I think that we're
sorta being this is just being pushed on
it again like oh now chairman
and now Hillary and then it's going to
be Maleah 2024 in Chelsea
20-30 years which those to you know you
know want
Americans like it and you know why
Americans like it
because John Kennedy said it best
what Americans really want is a kind
king
that is reversal now
to do that as the adams is or bush's
or john kennedy with the kennedys
Robert would have been president right
Ted via maybe town didn't have
chappaquiddick human
we'd like that its as in something
inside of us likes the fact
we have this family protector
it's a god-like thing there are
protectors you know and it seems sorta
backwards though to have our country was
born because we left England begins
yeah so what do you think that there's
about because I think and he had a right
we would like to try and King winners
know this is a make just on bars norse
don't rose in jail for a crime he didn't
commit
yeah on prevent us from doing things we
want to do be nice
yeah just be nice don't and up citizens
off to war with gonna get killed a
blessing to really just servants
be nice kind king and King a
well on that note I got I got two more
for real-time K
you're attacking I can tell I'm feeling
the kind as arm
how do you like being on this side have
do you like being interviewed
a Peter Ustinov to great actor once I
assume that
if you like the movies I love being
interviewed because it makes me think
about things I don't think about
knows I don't drive around all day
interviewing myself
so before since you think so when it
when you're as good questions as you
been asking good questions it forces me
to think
I like to think when this stupid
questions
no them that personal life had someone
does
yeah %uh by the best answers so that was
a
I was a touring a book I wrote
written 16 books was to read a book and
I was on a show called
good morning Dallas I could tell you
right away
you can I could see right away you know
what the host and hostess lynn I
are I have something in my mind generic
gotta sit perfectly coiffed hair
and the woman have blonde hair popped
around trip and the woman was scheduled
to interview me
and she's as we grow I can see
she's really love to questions on a
peace pipe is not listening to my
answers
and while I'm answering up she's like
fishing are here
and the crew was the mom answering the
questions of fourth question was a
what makes a good talk show host
anti-civil
I don't love about other people I get so
she not listen
but what helps me the most is being in
the CIA
because well-being in the CIA what
happens is
paid they get me great guess and
I can't tip of spies around the world
and then she could goes on to a pinwheel
raising children is the I
that yeah and you know that she heard a
word you're saying you know
yeah I well you don't have the right on
the side of the table 2
because I have a look at my notes want
to I'm doing pretty good about this so
my final question to you
is a I can I can tell people you're
eighty years old right that
that public had a big that publisher age
group party was about the other side are
you sitting with that as bigger thrill
for your baseball guy with a role in the
shop yeah at the same time was to my
wife pulled over on how she pulled off
this at all those people up
yeah to walk into that stadium I thought
I was going to a meeting a season ticket
holders
was a logical they had a great ploy yeah
had a letter from the Dodgers to me
season ticket holder come on Friday
night was my birthday
but there was coming four days later hmm
I thought she was going to do something
on my birthday night
I was on Jimmy Kimmel on my actual
birthday
now was booked a long time ago so I port
they would take me somewhere
after jimmy Kimmel right that's right
por eso
total throughway the and they had like
almost 300 people there
home plate people who kids in uniform
playing baseball stadiums all that up
my pick up on the scoreboard Corbally I
could I just
I just I could believe to be I can see
it in your eyes I mean baseball really
or I grew up with it is said presuming
my boys play it
the biggest thrill I get in my life is
what you my kids
yeah play I was not a good athlete
baseball family West Saturday
my son pitch for Notre Dame freshman
season
while freshman high school and
I watched him on the mound and he's you
know like as one guy sat next to me
since we
back it's a ballplayer just way moves
he's got
swagger and me more baseball there's a
move an athlete has you can open as a
player
he's a player is the way gives out the
dugout we have this is globally look
sleepy
was any the shutout innings and struck
out the side in the first inning
I'm saddened I'm jewish terms quelling
your clearly is when you get a thrill
for something else happens someone you
care about
and I was remembering the his birth
i cud cord them
and cut that open lead into the fourth
get yourself a No
now public i cud and I E
so unborn unknowns fifteen-years-old
pigeon nope be I'm out beautiful high
school field you know sort of feel like
to sleep
was just how could you top that so
nothing I bet than the eighty years
nothing top like think you answered my
final question here but how I wanted to
end this was
what do you think about my grandma would
always say what's it all about healthy
so what do you think eighty years you
interviewed live literally everybody
from every walk of life
you've talked to everybody listen to
everybody now
a father the whole thing what do you
think it's all about at the end of the
day
what do you think you know what
there was a famous a Nobel Prize winner
who lived in ninety five years ago
ending was a
dinner table and someone said
I forget shouldn't forget his name when
the 80 S that victim
what do you no 9b five
use well you know he said
and I would put this is my epitaph the
only thing I know sale
well on that was all about Alfie
I don't know I S the Stephen Hawking
this was the smartest person in the
world physicists in
you're the smartest person world what
don't you know
want to send to you don't know and he
said women
back I think he's married there is any
yes he is
i think is married for that the love it
because you're married you know
I exactly well on that note I want to
thank you this is crying in a bit
anytime I
really been a an honor for me and we'll
have you back on again you're a great
guest
I appreciate that you are a great cast
so you guys can check out Larry King now
and politicking on ora TV and on RT
and the wow I feel like I gotta go get a
drink it and it's been pretty great all
right thank everyone to david has been
trying
I done